so the puzzle is why out of nowhere in
the last decade have we seen a sudden
and sharp spike of teenage girls
who have no childhood history of gender
dysphoria suddenly deciding they're
trans
often with their girlfriends um and the
the numbers are quite alarming
we we now have you know between 2016 and
2017 the number of young women
asking for gender surgeries quadrupled
in the united states
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report joining me today for a long
overdue
interview is author of the new book
irreversible damage the transgender
craze seducing our daughters abigail
schreier welcome to the reuben report
thanks so much for having me on so the
book came out
in june and kind of caught fire in june
and then i was going to have you on in
august and i went off the grid
and then you know there was election
stuff so i didn't have yan
and then a couple weeks ago all hell
broke loose because
target tweeted that they were gonna no
longer
carry the book so let's just start with
the controversy because actually the
reason i'm having you on
right now is that after the controversy
uh the book
absolutely sold out everywhere and we
had to hold this interview
so that the book would be stocked again
so a lot's going on so let's just start
with the controversy
first because the what you write about
here in the transgender
craze is really like the hot topic of
the day and the thing that seems to get
the most people in hot water so what
happened with target let's start there
sure so look you know we're living
through probably the biggest medical
scandal today is that there's a sudden
spike in these teenage girls
out of nowhere medically transitioning
all of a sudden they want hormones and
surgeries they're easily obtaining them
and um i wrote a book about it and
because
two twitter users decided the book was
transphobic
um they told that they called it that to
target target removed it
and people were very upset you know the
book has a lot of grassroots support a
lot of parents feel like
it really explained the story of what
happened to them when their teenagers
suddenly out of the blue decided with
their friends that they were transgender
and um they were really upset and a lot
of people wrote to target and target
you know reinstated it it was you know
you know
one of the few victories i think against
cancel culture
yeah you must have been pretty enthused
to see the amount of support that you
got because yeah you get the usual
twitter haters and the anonymous
accounts and all that stuff
you know pushing target to a decision
like this but
but pretty much everybody that still
stands on the side of free speech i
guess we don't have that many people
anymore but
pretty much everyone that was around
supported you to get this thing back and
it actually did work
yeah i was very gratified look you know
there are literally
hundreds of books out there promoting
unskeptically the immediate medical
transition of teenagers
if you want to read that book there are
hundreds you can read and and you know
what
i you know i i certainly would never
call for any of them to be banned
because i don't want to live in that
kind of world
but you know there is exactly one book
that did a deep dive into this
phenomenon
of teenage girls suddenly transitioning
and it's my book
and for the activists even one book is
too many
yeah okay so let's start with the most
important conversa
question let's just get it out there
right from the top abigail are you a
transphobe do you have an irrational
fear of trans people and is that why you
wrote this book
no i wrote the book first of all because
a reader wrote to me and she told me her
daughter had gone through this
phenomenon
and when she um you know she said her
daughter had always been a girly girl
never had gender dysphoria this is um
severe discomfort and one's biological
sex
but when she got to high school she had
a lot of mental health issues and she
went off to college
and with a group of girlfriends they all
decided they were transgender and
she started a course of testosterone and
i tried to find another investigative
journalist who would take it up
because i had you know i wasn't an
investigative journalist and i couldn't
find one
so after four months i finally got back
in touch with her and i said all right
i'll do it i mean that's
that's the world we're living in and let
me just say that a lot of transgender
adults and i interviewed a lot from my
book
support the book i mean the book does
not i'm not against medical transition
it just urges caution when it comes to
these teenage girls
okay so just to be absolutely clear and
i know my audience totally
understands it but so you don't have a
problem with
adults that transition that make the
choice in their lives to transition
no i mean not only am i not against it
i've interviewed a lot of transgender
adults i believe it has helped
um trans it can help um i i know them i
talk to them and i'll tell you something
else i'm not even against
all medical transition for teenagers the
only thing i
i show in the book is that the current
medical regime
has no medical judgment in place it's
totally based on the judgment of
teenagers
and the doctors are told to affirm
affirm a firm meaning they have to agree
with the teenager self-diagnosis
so there's no checks in place so the
regime the current medical regime is
really not safe for teenage girls
yeah so i was trying to think how i
wanted to conduct this interview because
you know this is
one of the topics that we've touched on
a bunch here not because
i particularly care about these issues
as much as
when it's become such a hot button issue
then it sort of gets to my plate but i
thought i read the book
and i thought that the way that you laid
it out just even in the chapters the way
you
separated certain things was really good
so if you don't mind we'll just go
through chapter by chapter and and
discuss
each one so the introduction is about
the contagion
and that's sort of what you're hitting
on about what happened with uh with your
friend's daughter at college can you can
you describe
that sure so um it's based on the you
know research of lisa littman as we'll
talk about the next chapter but um
the public health researcher who looked
into why there was a sudden and huge
spike in teenage girls
who claimed to have gender dysphoria and
this is not the population that
traditionally had it it was always
males and it usually began in early
childhood and all of a sudden across the
west including america
we have the sudden spike of teenage
girls
deciding they're transgender often with
their friends and often
after the encouragement of social media
influencers
right so you talk about this a little
bit later in the book so i'm jumping
ahead a bit but you tell a story of a
girl
who in essence in high school came out
as transgender there there weren't a lot
of
issues that she was bringing up before
that but then suddenly she's getting
more likes on tumblr
she's now part of an oppressed minority
at school and in different groups
and that that allure basically and i
know i'm getting a little ahead of
ourselves here but but that allure in a
weird way
is what's fueling so much of this that's
right so it's young
teenage girls these are often white
middle or upper middle class girls
they're very precocious
but they are high anxiety and high
depression girls they have a lot of
mental health issues
and for the first time the moment they
get to high school and or in middle
school and decide they're transgender
you know it's the first time they get so
much encouragement and love
especially online and sometimes from
adults
and and some of these adults are not you
know are not up to
to very much good um but they get the
showering of love and praise and they
don't want to walk away from that so
chapter one which is about the girls
that you're describing right there you
know we've talked a lot about and i
think you know i was on tour with jordan
peterson for a year and a half and and
he focused
more so i would say on young men but it
was a message that obviously
traversed it didn't matter what gender
you really were but is there something
specific
going on with young girls that we're not
aware of like there does seem to be an
emasculation of young boys that we see
but what do you think is happening with
young girls right
so teenage girls specifically fall for
almost every one of these so-called
hysterias and the reason they do
is they tend to take on their friends
pain if a young man is depressed very
often
his friend will say okay let's go play
basketball or
or suggest doing something but he won't
say what are you feeling
tell me about your pain and he won't
start to take it on himself he won't
agree with his friend
about how terrible life is just to make
his friend feel better
but we know and i interviewed a lot of
psychologists about this young women
tend to not only take on their friends
pain they're willing to distort reality
in order to make their friend feel
better um and and so that's why they
tend to you know all of these
you know um anorexia is spread this way
they tend to
you know take on whatever their their
friend's reality is
even if it's oh i'm too fat um whatever
they they think will make their friend
feel better they'll take that on
do you get pushback when even you talk
about something sort of as
simple and kind of obvious like we all
know that is true men care more about
things women care more about people like
these are things that we all know
but even saying something like that do
you find that you get pushed back from
the scientific community on that that
just boys and girls are wired a little
bit differently and of course there's
object
exceptions to the rule but as a general
rule what you just said is is true
right so i i do get some pushback but
but actually i get a lot of you know i
interviewed a lot of people from the
book and a lot of scientific experts and
a lot of them agree i mean we know that
you can't house young women who are
anorexic
in hospital worlds together without
being really careful because they will
tend to encourage each other
and their anorexia will get more severe
and and it's we don't
it's not comparable with boys um they
don't they don't go through quite the
same things
so chapter two is the puzzle let's talk
about the puzzle
so the puzzle is why out of nowhere in
the last decade
have we seen a sudden and sharp spike of
teenage girls
who have no childhood history of gender
dysphoria suddenly deciding they're
trans
often with their girlfriends um and the
the numbers are quite alarming we we now
have you know between 2016 and 2017
the number of young women asking for
gender surgeries quadrupled in the
united states
so we we know and we know it's it's
typically teenage girls who are driving
this democrat
driving this population um so so the
question is why what is it about teenage
girls
whenever you have a any kind of
you know diagnosis that's exploding it
really is
important to ask why and you know
we're not seeing this with women in
their 60s and 70s we're seeing the same
population that falls for every other
uh peer contagion so
what would you say the the well you get
to this a little bit later but what
would you say is
sort of the the answer to the puzzle i
mean
is it is it it's just a confluence of
many things education social media
everything right
right and and young women who are in
genuine psychological pain and these
women
are they tend to look to the culture to
help them understand it so in previous
generations they might have said oh i'm
so fat that's the problem if i just lose
this weight i'll feel better
and today they look in the culture and
say oh i know what this is i don't feel
perfectly feminine
i'm 13 i hate my body i must have gender
dysphoria i'm supposed to be a boy
yeah and that's one of the hardest
things there because you have you have
girls that have legitimate issues
that they need to deal with that adults
should be there to
to deal with them and yet they're being
prescribed the wrong thing
you might even say that's the entire
issue the entire issue is really
and here's the problem it's not that
transition is never appropriate
but we are living with this affirmative
care model now
which means that across the west doctors
are told with this diagnosis
you must agree with the patient no
matter how young she is or what her
other mental health issues
when she self diagnosis with gender
dysphoria you agree with her and your
next question is basically when do we
start the medication
um there's no oversight yeah so
it's an interesting segue to the
influencers which is the next chapter
i'm really fascinated by this on how
this stuff spreads
yeah so um there are a lot of social
media influencers and
you know for gen z those born in 1995
and after
you know social media influencers are
are as important
if not more important than hollywood
stars they really follow these people
they look up to them
and unfortunately there are a lot of
trans influencers who are peddling very
very bad messages
like transition is easy even if you
don't know if you're trans you should
try
a course of testosterone because that's
the only way to find out if you're the
real thing
and they really downplay the medical
side effects which are really severe and
irreversible
so what do you make of the click part of
this the people that are influencers
that keep talking about this stuff even
if they don't understand the science
even if they themselves are not
trans but that for some reason there
seems to be a tremendous amount
of just clicks i mean literally just
clicks and eyeballs
that seem to drive this right so one
thing is
you know i interviewed influencers for
my book and and i do think
some of them really believe they're
helping and one of the reasons they
and they do genuinely feel great about
having transitioned and one of the
reasons they do
is because testosterone delivers a
euphoria
and it suppresses anxiety which is some
of these girls biggest problems
so they go on it and they think it's
confirmation
that they got their diagnosis right and
they feel great
and they can't wait to tell their
friends the problem is we're already
seeing
long-term you know when you step out of
even just a few years there's tremendous
rates of regret
and there's tremendous rates of anxiety
and depression it is not curing
depression in many instances
and there really was no medical
oversight for it
yeah and there's really nothing that can
be done about that right i mean about
about the influencers that for either
good intentions or bad intentions i mean
it is what it is we're all online yeah i
mean i you know
get getting some of these young girls
offline is a good first step look
when there was lots of i think they
called it thin spo you know the thin
inspiration on i think it was instagram
or one of one of these social media
sites
they took it down because inspiring
girls to anorexia was harmful
but right now we have trans influencers
people who are suggesting and
encouraging
taking testosterone trying it out seeing
how it feels
basically online and they it's basically
a wild west they're never
shut down because you know whenever
someone says it's a matter of civil
rights or a minority
everyone stops thinking and certainly
social media
doesn't police it at all how long do
they
when when people start taking or when
these young girls start taking
testosterone how long does that
that bump that you described there last
where the anxiety is going to go down
and that sense of euphoria
i've talked to um trans adults
who've said it lasted their whole life
in other words they really felt that
that um in their case that
testosterone was a really helpful drug
um
the the the and i you know i'm fine with
that the only problem of course is that
in the trans adults i talked to
they had to have certain therapy you
know therapy to make sure
and there was oversight to make sure it
was the correct diagnosis
because right now teenage girls are
deciding this on their own
and there there isn't mental health
oversight
um in any meaningful way right so we'll
get more to the to the medical
part of that a little bit but so chapter
five is about the schools and i i think
this is kind of fascinating because
we've sort of just
watched intellectual rot run across
all of our schools and you you just have
to kind of go with whatever
the thing of the day is
um how much of this is just sort of
being taught
at public schools do you think i know it
depends what state you're in but here we
are
both in cali so in california or worse
right it's very extreme in this state so
it gender identity education is
something you can't opt out of it begins
in kindergarten
and it's really extreme we start by
teaching you know five-year-olds that
whatever however they were born a doctor
just made a guess and only they know
their true gender
and this doesn't push kids to transition
necessarily but what it does do is the
moment these
young girls in particular hit
adolescence they go through a period
where they hate their own bodies they
feel ugly this is something nearly every
woman will can attest to
um the the solution readily leaps to
mind because it's something they've
learned about for years and
and it's that oh my gosh i know why i'm
so uncomfortable in my body it's because
i'm supposed to be a boy
were you able to figure out at all how
these bad ideas get
so influential at all the schools
seemingly all the schools at least in
california but
but new york too and all over the
country just how infectious the ideas
are
right so i was a little bit because i
was able to get a lot of documents out
of the california teachers association
concerned teachers send them sent them
to be uh
sent them to me and um there are
there's really no division in california
between the activists
and the teachers activists are not only
training the teachers
they are um providing all the curriculum
for you know gender identity and sexual
orientation education
so it's coming from very extreme sources
and
in teachers who are a little
uncomfortable about it are completely
intimidated into silence
so when you say that at five years old
they're they're taught this
um for the average parent that might go
into that school and say well i don't
want my child hearing that at five years
old which no five-year-old it has
nothing to do with even what's true or
not
no five-year-old can comprehend this
stuff that that in in effect that person
is going to be blacklisted and god only
knows what they'll do to the poor kid
that's right um you can't because in
california they did something really
sneaky
they put this curriculum into the
anti-bullying curriculum so usually you
would
think this would go into the sex ed
curriculum which parents are allowed to
opt out of
but they put it into the anti-bullying
curriculum under the pretext that you
couldn't possibly police bullying unless
you taught
every child that only they know their
true gender
and of course we know that's nonsense
because you you can absolutely police
bullying and should police bullying
against sexual minorities and every
other student without
introducing everybody to a to a
false ideology yeah do you have any
numbers on what percentage of the public
school teachers
like actually buy it versus who's just
going along i guess that would be hard
to quantify
it's it's very hard public school
teachers are terrified i have i
spoke to one teacher who posted
something on social media it was very
tame
she said i don't know this seems to be
confusing a lot of kids at my school
effectively
and she was suspended immediately and
this was on her private um
facebook page so um teachers are very
very afraid
yeah so the next chapter is the moms and
dads which speaking of very very afraid
it seems like a lot of the moms and dads
are too
yeah they're afraid they're afraid to
lose custody and these are you know the
parents who called me are overwhelmingly
political progressives
they are proud allies they've always
been allies
but um the the their only sort of
hesitation is problem is they think
gosh this came out of nowhere i mean i
supported her when she said she was a
lesbian but now she's saying she's a boy
and she wants to have her breasts
removed i mean i'm not sure that's right
for her and
isn't couldn't she regret it these are
the most sort of
obvious questions there's there's
nothing hateful about these questions
but today these parents are treated like
bigots they're isolated their friends
dropped them
and very often friends will go behind
their backs to send their daughters
encouragement by way of a binder the one
of those compression garments
or otherwise you know castigate them for
for bigotry allegedly what did this
teach you maybe or you're a parent
yourself i mean did this teach you
anything about
parenting in general and and setting
rules and being honest
in the rest of it sure i think one thing
it taught me was
really how much we've over relied on
experts these so-called experts
who show up and claim to know more than
we do about our kids that we have spent
i don't know hundreds of thousands of
hours raising
and and i think that um i think that
trusting your own instincts about what's
right for your
daughter i mean if you in many cases
parents will call me and they
it just doesn't sit right with them but
they are being pressured
by the mental health establishment or
doctors to immediately agree with their
daughter and
and fast track her to irreversible
consequences that she's likely to regret
so since you said the p word
progressives do you
sense that there is a connection between
sort of being politically progressive
and that it would end up in a situation
like this that you sort of just yes
everything goes all the time there is
nothing that's really
true per se and everything is sort of
how you feel that this was the
the obvious outcome of it in a weird way
well i think my my take is that the
reason
so many progressive families have have
fallen
into this and and let me say
conservative families have as well but
the reason it's it does seem to be
majority progressive families
is because they were less skeptical of
the culture
um conservatives have known for a long
time that social a social worker or
psychologist
might not um treat their values with
respect
but liberals were genuinely taken aback
and completely caught off guard because
they thought wait a second i've been an
ally my entire life
this isn't about that it's about the
mental health of my daughter she's got
anxiety depression
shouldn't we look at those things first
and they were really assuming good
faith on behalf of um you know frankly
activists posing as doctors
yeah and we've just it seems to me that
that unfortunately for a lot of the
liberals and i think you know a little
bit about my story you know for a lot of
liberals until something like this hits
them
they think that there's there's nothing
wrong there that that it's just like oh
anything goes and then next thing you
know they're confronted with this and
then they feel a little bit differently
that's right they describe themselves
now overwhelmingly as politically
homeless
and it's not because they feel
conservative um it's because they
they're really horrified
that by the assault on their families i
mean
that that that all these medical these
mental health professionals and teachers
would go behind their backs
to encourage their children to do
something that they think is harmful to
them
is is so stunning to them and it really
it does make them
really uh uncomfortable with with
progressive politics
yeah so did you have a sense or do you
have a sense that conservative parents
have some better mechanisms to fight
this either by standing up to the school
or
maybe dealing with the child a little
bit differently or whatever it might be
yeah it's interesting i think
conservative parents
were tended to be and and should be you
know
more skeptical of the culture they were
more skeptical of these social workers
and
and and psychologists who claim to know
so much about their parents
but they also look their you know their
their default is that what do you mean
you're
suddenly a boy see sometimes progressive
parents were afraid to say that because
they don't want to be bigoted
but a conservative parent is it might be
more comfortable just saying what do you
mean you've been a girl your whole life
you're a girl i mean
just because you want a short haircut
doesn't suddenly make you a boy
yeah are you worried that the slippery
slope of this
ultimately is that you know a child will
a girl a young girl will basically
announce that she's trans at school
a parent or the parents will say well
we're not transitioning you something
like that and then as the state grows
and again we're both in california
that literally the state will start
taking kids away from their parents like
is that
something that that you think is really
legit it's it's already happening i mean
just you especially
hear that now where where with divorce
divorce couples where they're not on the
same page
the i i've had i've been called by a
mother who was
you know she was divorced but she had
full custody of the daughter
because the court deemed her the more
responsible better parent
and when the daughter hit 13 out of
nowhere she decided she was trans with
the encouragement of her therapist and
and her stepmom and the moment the mom
said the mom put the brakes on it and
said honey you don't
look you know and and the mom was not
gender
conforming herself the mom said honey
look you're you're still a girl
just because you you know you don't want
to dress early that's fine
um then then the um a social worker was
brought in and decided that
um the mom was no longer a safe parent
god i mean it's just it's it's twisted
it's deeply twisted what about on the
parent side where we've seen some
stories like this i can think of one
from about two months ago
where it really seems to be the parent
that's driving this that the stuff we
talked about earlier about oh you
suddenly are getting a lot of likes on
tumblr
or you're feeling like you're in a group
suddenly that we've heard some instances
where it seems like the parents are the
ones driving their children towards this
because then they
sort of by proxy feel popular or liked
or
or as an oppressed they're an oppressed
group
adjacent or something right so i i think
that does happen
um the population i really looked at was
is the biggest population it's this teen
girl population and the re and
and there you don't you know these are
young women who aren't listening to mom
at all in fact the last thing they want
is advice for mom
and so usually in that instance the
parents aren't
so much the driver sometimes with the
little kids you do see parents who they
you know who seem to be pushing this
awfully hard and certain
certainly seem to be bragging about it
online in ways that
make you wonder if they aren't getting
something else out of it
yeah all right the shrinks are up next i
know that you're you're not thrilled
with the way therapists have dealt with
this
yeah i mean they have an affirmative
model right now the majority although i
interviewed look i interviewed you know
a lot of giants in the field who don't
agree with it and are not affirmative
therapists
but affirmative therapy says we start
from the conclusion
we know that we're going to agree with
that that a young person
who says they're gender dysphoric we're
going to agree that that's the right
diagnosis
we'll affirm them as transgender and the
only question is when do we get started
on the medications
and um you know that's that's just not
medicine
medicine is an evaluation of risks and
benefits
and the moment you are open about the
risks and benefits of any medical
treatment
you're you're not in the gender
affirmative camp anymore you're
you're on my side of things which is to
have an open look
and and approach with some skepticism
how these
girls are what and whether they're
benefiting so do you sense that the
that some of the psychologists or the
psychiatrists that they're actually
not telling these young girls the what
the numbers are in terms of
either regretting it later in life or
that it's not going to solve all of your
problems
or or that suicides are still high i
mean
all of these things that are
uncomfortable to talk about i mean do
you sense that they kind of hide that
because they're they're just on board
well
remember that we have 20 um conversion
therapy laws that prohibit them
from doing anything other than affirming
because that might be considered
you know the so-called conversion
therapy might be trying to convert them
out of being trans
now so in essence in essence they can
lose their license they could lose their
license
um now of course conversion therapy the
reason we passed these bans
was to it was to eliminate the really
ugly practices
of gay conversion therapy that's how
they got passed
but they inserted activist inserted
gender identity language so now a
therapist can't even say to a child
hold on i know you say you're a boy but
let's explore some of the other things
that seem to be upsetting you
yeah can you clean that up a little bit
for people that have nothing
no knowledge of any of this the sort of
difference between sexual
identity meaning your sexuality verse
verse gender identity and why
conversion in in each case or conversion
therapy in these cases is not exactly
apples to apples sure so with
homosexuality you know
um we've all you know we've long known
that this is
it seems to be innate and immutable it's
not the kind of thing you can
sort of convert someone out of or
convince them out of
and nor should you want to i mean this
is
there's nothing unhealthy about a gay
life there just
isn't but when you're talking about um
you know these the letting a child
become comfortable in their own body
because gender identity if a young woman
suddenly says i'm really a boy i need to
become a boy
you're setting them up to be a lifetime
medical patient
where they will put testosterone in
their bodies they need to stay on it for
life
it has all kinds of terribly extreme
side effects that are highly risky um
and
and unlike you know therapy that may
make her comfortable
in her body the today's therapy pushes
her
to transition um that's very different
from from being gay in which all the gay
person asks is that you accept them for
what you
what they are what what a you know what
a trans teen asks is you can you help me
try to be what i'm not and that's a much
more invasive intervention
yeah you know i'm reminded as you're
talking about this i i'm blanking on
whether you mentioned the show in the
book did you talk about transparent at
all the show
no i didn't so i in there's a line in
the
last episode of the first season where
a woman who's already transitioned says
to the main character who's about to
begin the process
in effect this is going to ruin your
life this is going to ruin your family
and that in many ways is what the show
ended up being about now i know that's
not about a child transitioning
but i think a lot of what you're talking
about is just that so many people just
don't
have a holistic view of what this is
going to be like
on the other side that's exactly right
and when i interview transgender adults
who are very happy in their transitions
very often
they will still tell me look this is not
easy it's not
easy to go through life on all this
hormonal treatment
you know holding yourself out as a
member of the opposite says
it's really hard and when when
transgender adults talk to me about it
they are horrified that
teenagers are getting this so this this
hormonal treatment
so easily without any kind of
understanding of the risks
and you know and not appreciating how
hard medical transition really is
so all that being said chapter seven is
about the dissidents there
there are some dissidents in the field
that's right a number of prominent
people have stood out and said hold on
this is way too much way too fast with
too little medical oversight
um you know look the court found you
know and i
interviewed a lot of them including you
know ken zucker who chaired the entry
the the writing of the entry on gender
dysphoria for the dsm
five the the classic psychiatric manual
and jet on
on mental disorders and um you know
these are people who say
starting with the conclusion is not
medicine
right and in fact last week um a
the british high court examined the same
protocols that they have in place in
britain for gender medicine
and the the high court was appalled they
said you know
in effect what's been going on here is
likely to transition
a lot of young women who are not
supposed to be
transgender and a lot of you know young
people who are likely to experience
severe regret
so are you are you surprised
i guess this is the right chapter to ask
you about this are you surprised the
amount
how this thing has become so part of the
culture war
that it's not just okay this is
happening to young girls at school
that's one portion of it but this is
becoming something
that you know that joe biden is tweeting
about transgender violence all the time
and kamal is saying or
elizabeth warren i think kamala said it
too about you know black
transgender women are the backbone of
the economy i mean like really crazy
stuff that
no one's against transgender people but
just how
this has become such a part of the
zeitgeist like this is like a bellwether
thing
where you either accept it or or you're
a dissident you're a bad guy
yeah it really has you know it's so
interesting when i first wrote a
proposal for my agent it was actually
going to be on a contemporary book about
feminism i had written one article about
this whole sudden spike in teenage girls
identifying as trans thing
but it wasn't it certainly wasn't a
passion of mine and i wasn't intending
to
turn it into a book and my agent said to
me listen
that article you wrote seems to have
gotten a lot of attention
and frankly if what you're really
interested in is how young women today
are doing
it seems to be a really good way to
explore all the other issues you're
interested in like free speech and
and and how young women are faring today
so
it did end up being sort of this this
incredible
you know um lens for looking at so many
aspects of the culture so i i
you know i guess that's why it seems to
be at the nexus of a lot of different
things
yeah well that's why it's so fascinating
to me because over the years i've
interviewed a lot of people who suddenly
find themselves in the the
thick of the battle without really
wanting in on it they were just sort of
interested in something else and next
thing you know the battle comes to them
and even though i hadn't you know this
is the first time that we're actually
speaking one-on-one
when i saw the target thing i was like
i'm gonna go out on a limb and guess
that abigail's probably not
that combative probably didn't really
want all of this extra attention and
everything else so what has it been like
for you to be a dissident
in something that is so hard to talk
about
you know i wouldn't have written this
book
kind of if i didn't think a few things
if i didn't think what was going on
today is kind of madness
i i do believe we're going to look back
on this time and say what were we doing
i mean why were we letting you know very
upset
teenagers and a lot of pain immediately
medically transition
and risk their fertility and future
sexual dysfunction
so i think that's what the high court in
england just looked at last week it was
a major case that of course the
media and the u.s tried to ignore it and
mostly did but it was a huge case this
is a neutral tribunal and they looked at
the exact same protocols we have in
place today
and they were horrified they basically
said why are you know these young
kids can't give informed consent at 15
to eliminating their future fertility
what are we doing yeah but what about
for you personally
just like going through the headaches of
all of this and you know you were on you
were on joe rogan and then the spotify
people
you know some employees at spotify
basically wanted to kick him off spotify
fortunately then that didn't happen
everyone heard what what happened with
target but you're back in at target i
mean just
for you personally as someone that you
know you're you're now out there and you
you live in la i mean you're here
in this weird town you know just the
person
when i wrote the book i actually worried
that it would be completely ignored
little did you know i wasn't i was
surprised um a little bit but
but i had seen i wasn't completely
surprised and i'll tell you why because
i had watched
every scientist who has ever and many of
whom i interviewed in the book
who's ever you know come out against
affirmative therapy who's ever come out
and said hold on what's going on is
does just seems to have a lot of pure
influence or have said this isn't real
therapy there's no oversight every
scientist who's done that has been
cancelled and they've and sometimes
they've lost their jobs
and very often they've been really
caught off guard by the vitriol
and and the frankly bad faith on the
opposite side so
i at least had the benefit of their
example um and and i was
i was i was a little bit more prepared
for that right
has it cost you do you think
professionally i mean the book is
obviously doing
well now but do you think this will
ultimately close some other doors that
you may not even know about i i i'm sure
i mean i it you know it's a question i i
do believe that we're going to look back
on this age i mean look
you know in the in england where they
have the exact same medical protocols
and the exact same
um spike among adolescent girls because
they have the same social media we do
um they um you know the they
the economist and the uh times of london
both just named my book um to it best
books list for the year
so even though the legacy media in the
united states completely ignored my book
um in england um you know their their
media seems to have found it worthwhile
so um you know i'm hoping that the the
sanity at some point prevails
yeah you know i'm wondering i i wonder
if there's any numbers on this i'm sure
someone could figure it out but i find
whenever i just suddenly get like a
thousand hate tweets in a row
almost every single one of them if i
look at the bio of the people that send
it
has gender pronouns in there and i
always think it's so interesting that
you know the people that i suppose
purport to be
the most tolerant the most diverse the
most open that they're the ones that are
often sending the most
the most anger so i have i can only
imagine what you were opening up your
twitter to find
tolerant people yeah you can imagine
the sort of uh threats i get but i would
just say that you know
look i i know a lot of transgender
adults at this point and
i try to say this in any in every
interview because it's really true
the crazy woke activists do not speak
for them they don't represent these
crazies
and you know they they are not
represented by these crazies and i have
to say transgender people i've met are
some of the loveliest most sober
and and really insightful people i've
i've gotten to know so
you know these these woke activists they
are the same people leading
black lives matter and every other you
know extreme group today
and and they don't they don't represent
transgender people um certainly the ones
i'm
actually i kind of wanted to get there
can you talk a little bit about the
intersectional nature of this how it
went from
black lives matter to sort of black
trans lives matter that these things
all do sort of link together in the woke
mind
yeah it's very it's very similar i mean
it's an extreme ideology which judges
everybody according to their rank
and their rank is based on these you
know so-called victim classes
and you know the woke trans activists
are the same way the moment
you declare you're trans you are now
you you rise in their you know
intersectional
um pyramid and the problem with that is
a lot of
you know lonely teenagers i mean there
are a lot of problems with it but one of
them is that a lot of lonely teenage
girls
who are white girls they're members of
the oppressive majority
right as soon as they uh choose
a trans identity they finally get relief
they get a shield
from all the hate they're getting from
their peers
it's so pervasive it's just unbelievable
you know you mentioned some of the
adult trans people that you talk to and
obviously how
great they can be in society and happy
and everything else you mentioned
deirdre mccloskey
in the book who i've had on the show
who's one of our our great economists
and i wonder when you talk to any of
them when
when they talk about transitioning does
anyone
say that they actually you know and she
deirdre is probably in her
60s or 70s i suppose um
do any of them say oh i wish i had done
it earlier
um that's interesting um
[Music]
not usually um and i'll tell you why
because
they really believe even though they
obviously wish
that they could pass more easily um
certainly the
the male to female transgender adults
often wish they could pass more easily
and they struggle to pass
they also often will tell you that the
process they went through with the in
therapy
before they were allowed to immediately
transition they felt that that process
was a really good process
to make sure they were they were right
and that it wasn't some
you know other impulse or other mental
health issue at play
um so and the thing the thing that's
crazy right now about the discussion is
you know they the activists insist we
have to transition these kids
immediately because otherwise they'll
regret it later in life
well it's mostly biological men who
worry about that
um and yet they're making the case that
that should apply to teenage girls
i mean teenage girls who put this
testosterone in their bodies 10 to 40
times than the amount their bodies would
normally handle
they actually transition pretty well um
you know they get full beards they get
male pattern baldness
their voices change their physique
changes they don't have quite the same
barriers that that men
that men have when they transition to
women yeah you know you just mentioned
the passing
portion of this meaning that you can
transition from one sex to the other
and be thought of just sort of generally
as that sex
so it's easier in essence you're saying
for younger girls
to transition to boys and and be thought
of as boys as opposed to the other way
around and you think that probably
makes it the decision a little bit
easier well
this is what i'll say it's not that it's
easy because it's not i mean they will
always be smaller
they'll need a double mastectomy it's
not an easy road
um but but and and they end up very
often
needing hysterectomies and all these
follow-up surgeries are they're actually
quite uncomfortable and have
serious repercussions it's it's not that
it's easy
it's that the the the men are you know
biological men are making the argument
that i wish i could pass better as a
woman so i would we need to transition
these kids earlier
but there are there are no you know
because they maybe have stubble
or they they don't you know they don't
have a jaw that looks like a woman's
but the the case is less you know
obviously made for a woman who
transitioned to a man because other than
being
she'll be smaller ultimately than a
biological
male but you know i look i know trans
men who are very convincing um
and and and more so more convincing than
in
you know some of the trans you know
women that i know right
what do you make of the idea that that
some of this is actually
bizarrely anti-gay because people seem
to think that these letters all have
something to do with each other but
i i've sort of come around to this idea
that if you
you know we hear this that if you have
an effeminate
boy so a five or seven year old that is
effeminate who probably is
just a gay boy will grow up to be a gay
man
that a lot of these parents instead of
having to deal with the realities of
having a gay son
that in a weird sense it's almost like
oh it would actually be easier if if he
was just a girl he behaves like a girl
and that that in and of itself is oddly
anti-gay
yeah i i do think there's there's an
element of that there's an element of
that homophobia you you see it sometimes
because the parents
will see and and part of it is not
necessarily homophobia i should say
part of it's this uncomfortable um
discomfort of
you know i have this child who seems to
be like they might end up
gay i have to do something immediately
right parents feel like they have to
immediately intervene and do something
and they they feel this way about almost
everything about the kids lives that's
why they're called helicopter
parents right and and sometimes the the
answer is really just to leave them be
there's nothing okay they may emerge as
gay they may not
i guess time will tell but it doesn't
mean you have to do something
and um unfortunately in this age we
don't wait
the answer is always start a net course
of medication right now
and i do think that's played in did you
meet a lot of
i guess well your research obviously was
was about girls that were transitioning
uh to boys but did you meet or have you
talked to people that have focused on on
that idea of these sort of feminine boys
who then transition and then years later
they just realized oh i was just
a feminine gay boy
i actually don't know about that as a as
a larger phenomenon you know this is a
really recent phenomenon this
epidemic is in the last 10 years and it
really has been driven by teen girls
so with boys it's a harder it's harder
to track
because there have always been some
percentage of boys who naturally would
end up
as what we used to call transsexuals so
it's harder to say
in their case oh that's certainly you
know pure contagion or homophobia or
anything else at play but with the girls
we know this population never existed
never experienced gender dysphoria in
any numbers
um that were at all significant so in
fact there's no extant literature on
teen girls
transitioning who didn't have childhood
gender dysphoria at all
so um with it's a clearer case with the
girls
yeah all right let's move to chapter
eight the promoted and the demoted
we sort of hit on this a little bit
sure so um i think one of the things
sort of at play with all this is that
women have really
fallen in esteem in a broad in the
broader culture
um certainly vis-a-vis trans you know
people
and we see this all the time where young
girls are asked to
you know womanhood is denigrated um in
many ways
one of the ways is through porn young
kids are seeing porn and very violent
porn at very young ages on the internet
now it's widely available
it's quite violent and being a woman
doesn't seem so great to them
and then you see that you know
biological boys are able to out compete
them in sports no one stands up for them
i i think it's pretty clear that in the
competition between
you know girls and and trans you know
youth for in terms of esteem
in the broader culture girls have fallen
and and i do think girls are feeling
that
yeah so what who are they promoted then
within that
oh so i i think that you know sort of
being
transgender today has sort of written
risen in esteem
and look i i think it's good that a lot
of these taboos have fallen away i
certainly would never want
you know transgender people to be at all
mistreated or or not have full rights or
you know the same wonderful you know
open
treatment that anyone should should be
able to get um
so i the only question is are girls
rushing to transition for the right
reasons
yeah so chapter nine is about the
transition actually
and you know i think you know it's like
for this topic it's like a lot of people
know nothing about this and in a weird
way don't really have to know
anything about it but but what should
people know about
chapter nine and the transformation
itself sure i would just say that
transformation
transition gender transition is always
an uphill battle
it's really hard you know i interviewed
even forensic anthropologists who talked
about the bone structure taught me about
the bone structure that's so different
between
males and females including your even
the skull the way the forehead slopes is
different
and and the point of this is just that
transition's very hard medical
transition is very hard
it requires constant medicalization um
it comes with severe risks young women
are at risk not only of infertility
um you know and depending on when they
start sexual dysfunction
and all kinds of you know endometrial
cancer all kinds of things
um but but that it's you know this is
not a decision to be taken lightly and
unfortunately today it's taken so
lightly
that the biggest sort of risk of all is
regret
yeah so that's a perfect transition to
chapter 11 the way back
right so um one of the things i say in
the book is that i i do think
a few things young young women today
have to be told that being a woman is a
is a great
thing that being uncomfortable in your
body during puberty is completely normal
and and whatever kind of girl you are
you know same-sex attracted
heterosexual whatever kind of cool you
are is a perfectly great kind of girl to
be
and um and and being a woman actually is
way more wonderful and comes with a lot
more pleasures and joys than the current
culture
admits yeah and that's just something
that culture
i mean again this sort of gets back to
the family and culture and education and
everything else right there's there's
not one culprit here
yeah i i think that's right there are a
lot of forces trying to say that being a
woman is terrible today it's a victim
class a lot of
feminists have have decided it's a
victim class
i mean look at the way lesbians are
treated today um
their bars are disappearing they are
harassed a lot of lesbians have told me
that their social groups have had to go
online
because they are so often harassed by
you know
transgender adults who who put who claim
to be lesbians
and come on to them sexually um
you know this is a very it's it's it's
tough to be a woman today
and in in certain sense and and we've
lost
and not a lot of women are standing up
for women's rights and and the rights of
girls to be whatever kind of girl they
want to be
you know it's so fascinating because if
you would have said what you just said
there four years ago look what's
happening to lesbians being harassed
blah blah if you would have said that
four years ago people would have thought
oh
she means that people on the right or
christian conservatives
or something or coming after lesbians
and it's simply
well it barely exists at this point at
least in an american context
but what you're talking about is being
bullied by the trans people and saying
if you're not attracted to me now that
i've transitioned or something else
now you're a transphobe and it's that's
really fascinating how quickly that has
all shifted
yeah and it's the activists look i can't
tell you i've interviewed a lot of trans
women who will say who would be
horrified to make other women
uncomfortable make women uncomfortable
they would never harass women
but but unfortunately this activist
group is taking advantage i mean
you know you see this all over um in so
many ways smith college which was always
all women
now admits biological boys um
tran you know lesbians who try to have
their own social groups or bars
they're constantly harassed by
biological men who claim to be women
and are you know forcing their way in
battered women's shelters the same thing
um prisons in california if you say
you're a woman you get housed with the
women prisoners
and this is obviously very dangerous not
because transgender people are dangerous
of course but because
biological men pose dangers living in
close quarters of prison
with with biological women yeah which by
the way not to get too political on you
but joe biden even said you should be
allowed to choose
what prison you want to go to based on
your gender identity
i mean this you know yeah i i mean i
look i you know i happen to think that
you know how housing a biological woman
with a biological man in prison
has got to be cruel and unusual
punishment
and yet we're seeing men who are even
found guilty
of sexual violence you know sexual
assault
housed with female prince prisoners it's
really unconscionable
yeah so uh you do it afterward in the
book call it called the update so what
is
the update where are we at right now
well look i think people are waking up
to this issue they're seeing that
there's very often pure influence this
is not organic
but right now because this is being
pumped through the school systems
because kids are
seeing so much of you know getting so
much encouragement from social media
you're seeing this we are seeing this
younger and younger
um you know young teens suddenly
deciding they're trans and i would just
say
you know parents if you're if your kid
out of nowhere decides they're
transgender
and they're you know peer groups doing
the same thing and whatnot just be aware
that there's very often
you know pure influence or social media
influence at play
yeah well listen abigail thanks for
taking the time i'm sorry it took so
long and i know our social circles have
been getting closer and closer so
hopefully
when we're free citizens here in los
angeles we can do this over a meal or
something and we're going to put a link
obviously to the book down below
hopefully it'll be back in stock by the
time we
put it up but who knows we'll see right
now as we tape this
it's completely sold out everywhere
right that's right but they're they're
getting them back into stores i'm told
so hopefully
all right well thanks for taking the
time i appreciate it thank you
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about women's
issues instead of non-stop yelling check
out our women's issues playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist they're both right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell